prends juste le
vol, la
lumière est meilleure qu'hier et bien nous
avons la lumière juste derrière nous ouais ouais
oh une ombre en sort Ombre
avec le polariseur comme ça
l'eau devient très sombre
ouais en fait ça a l'air un peu
euh gris  juste là, nous aurons un
reflet du coup, faites juste une pause un
instant
2 29 Nord
12 Je me demande à quoi ressemblerait cette photo à
l'envers Je vais l'essayer I Je n'arrive pas à
y croire mais nous avons mis l'Horizon
tout droit  au milieu de l'image
et et il y a des choses similaires blanches sur
bleu et blanc sur noir et gris sur bleu
et à droite
disparaissent ok
[Musique]
car
oh là ça devient un peu
gris au niveau des
nuages ​​ok
pause
[Rires]
venant de l'image satellite
venant de l'
image satellite, nous partons de
là,
mec, donc encore une fois, nous sommes
en route,
mil
minutes s'il vous
plaît
Peter, pensez-vous que c'est comme des montagnes
là-bas, nous
voyons, je ne peux pas, je ne regarde pas, je vais jeter un œil
une minute allez ok je
regarde juste vers la droite oh désolé je
fais un
tir
ok pause de je s'il te plaît gentil comme ça
oh nous allons de droite à gauche dans l'autre
sens o nous y sommes arrivés c'est inhabituel
pour ça  travail oh mon Dieu je vais juste
redresser ce nuage en haut
tu es droit
en ce moment
nous avons un peu de dérive latérale sur
nous
ouais s'il te plaît sois
h
non c'est une belle
photo ok
arrête
hé cherche-moi, je
pense que tu peux  faites une photo verticale totale
sur l'un de ces
gars du pack qui travaillent comme ça, vous ne voyez pas
ça parce que cela pourrait correspondre à l'
image satellite, peut-être que nous volons un peu, je veux dire, euh, nous allons
trop vite dans la photo, je ne suis pas
sûr  peut-être
pas
pour
ok, probablement assez, je
pense que encore 5 secondes plus tard, je vais m'incliner
ouais
ça marche
parfaitement, ouais, fais encore la même chose
mais sans le petit
avion là-bas mais ça a l'air sympa
ouais, je vais juste à partir de là attendre que nous obtenions
un peu de glace BS ok juste une pause nous devons
attendre,
ça a l'air sympa mais il n'y a pas
assez de
glace oh d'
accord ok pause s'il te plaît
là-bas d'
accord laisse ce premier lot
passer un peu mieux mais il n'y a pas
assez de glace
assez dur pour placer
peut-être celui-ci  c'est bien mémorisé cette fois
je vois ce gamin ouais ok en ce moment grosse
grande lampe d'
yeux c'est parti
VOA ok pause s'il te plaît merci
on s'est incliné un peu comme là
ouais je pourrais faire signe ouais c'était
bien ouais tout en vraiment lisse ceci un
autre plan nous  peut avoir un petit
reflet sur la
fenêtre ouais c'est Focus autour
d'
un autre plan sous un autre angle ouais c'était
sympa avec ça euh là réfléchis hé
har si tu bouges juste le collectif
L alors à droite euh que l'horizon
restera le même et l'hélicoptère le
fera  bouge euh sur le côté du plan de
ce côté ouais tourne juste à
droite tourne juste B bang à droite tu
vois comme ça ok vois comme ça maintenant
frappe encore à gauche
même fais-le un peu plus
extrême
ouais maintenant bang à  la
gauche maintenant, redresse-toi à
nouveau ok pause s'il te plaît
oh nous avons perdu un
peu oh
ici nous descendons encore un
peu tu veux ralentir non non non non
continue comme ça nous arrivons à un
bon patch d'
IC ​​qui arrive la
seconde  nous ne sommes jamais allés aussi
loin en construisant
[Musique]
c'est la fin,
ok, pause s'il te plaît